В мене таки на побутовому
рівні англійська мова зараз.
Я її навчався, починаючи
з дитячого садка.
Правда, з англійською мовою – це,
мабуть, мій найбільший сором в житті.
Я чесно кажу, тому що я собі
обіцяю кожного року вивчити
на хорошому рівні англійську, тому
що в наш час – час глобалізації –
українська і ось тут,
поруч, має стояти англійська.
Не якась інша мова, а саме
українська і англійська.
Ось це – дві основні
мови, які ви маєте знати.
Hello guys!
Hello!
It’s time for English lesson.
My name is Nataliia Liashko.
So, let’s have an English.
So, today we are going to talk about
free time activities. Let’s start!
Free time activities – this is
something that we do after school.
So, leisure time. What can we do?
We can do some sports, we can
do – what else? Watch TV. Okay?
So, I prepared some pictures,
let’s look at the pictures
and try to guess what’s
this. What’s this?
Piano.
Yes, so we play the piano. Can you
repeat after me – play the piano?
Play the piano.
Jean?
Fantastic. Let’s move on. What’s this?
XBOX?
XBOX, yes. So, we… If it is an activity?
So, we play the piano or we play…
Video games?
Yes! We play computer
games. Absolutely right.
So, play the piano, play computer games.
Can you say it – play computer games?
Play computer games.
Fantastic, Zhenia! Jean?
Thank you! Okay, we
move on. What’s this?
Balls?
Yes. Okay. If it is an activity?
Sport?
Sport. So, what do we do?
Do some sports.
Exactly, thank you, Jean!
So, we do sports. We do sports.
Can you repeat, Zhenia, please?
Do sports.
Yes, exactly. Okay. Now,
can you guess this activity?
Ballet?
Ballet, yes.
Do ballet?
Exactly, we do sports and we do
ballet. Do ballet. Let’s repeat.
Do ballet.
One more time!
Listen to me: “balley”
(pronounciation).
“Balley”.
Yes, do ballet.
Do ballet.
Do ballet. Okay.
Some more. What’s this?
Fishing?
Okay, what do we do with
fishing? Do? Play fishing?
Go?
Go fishing, exactly. We go
fishing. And what about this?
Microphone?
Singing.
Yes.
Go singing.
Go singing, fantastic!
Listen to me: go singing.
Go singing.
Fantastic! Jean?
Perfect! And something more. What do
we usually do every day? We work with…
Computer?
With computer we
work with the internet.
We look through the internet,
we find the information.
So, this is something new
for you – surf the net.
Surf the net. You can write
this down – surf the net.
A new word for you. Шукати
в інтернеті – surf the net.
And what about this one?
Movie.
Movie. So, what do
we do with the movie?
Watch the movie.
Watch the movies, yes! Or
watch films, okay? Watch films.
So, let’s revise. We
had 8 activities. Okay?
8 pictures. What was number 1?
Play piano.
Play the piano, okay.
What do we do with this?
Play computer games.
Fantastic.
Do sports.
Do sports, good.
Do ballet!
Do ballet.
Go fishing.
Go fishing!
Go singing.
Go singing!
Surf the net!
Bravo! Surf the net. And the last
one. Jean, can you tell me the last one?
Watch the film.
Watch films, bravo!
Now, it’s time for the game.
Let’s play the game. Ready?
Do you like games?
Yes? Do you play games?
I like football.
You like football.
What about you, Jean?
I'm wrestler.
Oh, you love wrestling!
This is really nice.
Okay, this is gonna be a different
game. This is educational game.
So, I'm gonna show you the
pictures. 8 pictures. Remember?
8 малюнків. Try to
guess – what’s missing.
What’s missing – чого не
вистачає? Okay? What’s missing?
Surf the net.
Bravo, Jean! Okay, surf the net.
Can you repeat, please,
altogether? Surf the net.
Surf the net.
Bravo! Okay, let’s try
again. What’s missing?
Do sports.
Bravo, Zhenia! Do
sports. Okay. And this one?
Go to ballet.
Ah, what do we do with ballet?
Do ballet!
Do ballet, yes! Let’s
repeat altogether – do ballet.
Do ballet.
One more time.
Bravo! Okay. And with the internet?
Surf the net.
Bravo! Now it’s time for some
grammar. Do you like grammar?
No.
No? Why? This is nice. It’s grammar!
It’s difficult.
It’s difficult… We’ll see.
Let’s have a lesson with me and then
you tell me – easy or difficult. Okay?
Okay.
Agree?
Yeah.
Okay. So, we’ll talk –
how often do you do this?
So, how often do you play the piano?
How often do you go singing? Як
часто – how often? This is called…
А often чи “offen” (pronunciation)?
Often. Often, yes. We can
say both – “offen”/often.
Let’s say, modern English say
often but “offen” is also possible.
Okay.
So, it’s not a mistake.
“Offen” or often. Okay?
So, how often do you do sports?
Everyday.
Everyday, fantastic!
Okay. Jean, what about you,
how often do you do ballet?
Never.
Never. Bravo, good. And how often
do you watch films? Both of you.
Three times a week.
Three times a week, that’s
nice. What about you, Jean?
Not so often.
It’s okay. We talk about
прислівники частотності –
adverbs of frequency. How
often do we do things. Okay.
And if we do something like ballet –
you don’t do it at all – we say never.
So, as an example: I never go
singing. Can you repeat, please?
I never go singing!
I never go singing.
Or, as you, Jean. I never do ballet.
I never do ballet.
Yes, bravo. The next one – sometimes.
So, this is something
more than never. Right?
And what can we do sometimes?
Sometimes – and this is about
me – sometimes I do sports.
Okay? What about you, Zhenia?
Sometimes, what do you do sometimes?
I sometimes go singing.
Okay. I sometimes go singing.
Can you repeat, please?
I sometimes go singing.
Bravo! Jean, what about
you? With sometimes.
I sometimes go fishing.
Bravo! This is nice. So, if we
do it more often – we say often.
Never, sometimes, often,
okay? I often go fishing.
You sometimes go fishing,
I often go fishing. Okay?
What about you, Zhenia?
What do you do often?
I often surf the net.
Bravo! Jean?
I often... watch film.
Watch films, okay.
Can you repeat again?
I often watch films.
Bravo! The next one is usually.
Never, sometimes, often,
usually. Can you repeat, please?
Usually.
Usually, what can we do usually?
I usually play computer
games. Okay? What about you?
Maybe, surf the net, usually.
I usually surf the net.
Bravo, Jean?
I usually do sports.
Do sports, this is
really nice. And always.
Always means every day.
So, what do I do always?
I always watch films. Every day I
watch films. What about you, Jean?
I always surf the net.
Surf the net.
And you, Zhenia?
Not often, not usually,
I always surf the net.
You always surf the net.
I thought jean would say:
“I always do sports”. No?
Too, I always do sports.
Yeah, too.
Now, when we have a
quarantine, it is only usually.
Only usually, okay. Hopefully,
will do it faster. Okay?
We’ll finish the quarantining period
and you will do more often again.
Of course.
So, again. Never, sometimes,
often, usually, always.
These 5 words we are
going to use today. Okay?
So, one more game for you, okay?
And for this we need a dice. So…
Dice? Кубик?
Dice, yes, this is a dice.
Dice – кубик. Yes, dice.
So, I will ask you to make up
a sentence. Your own sentence.
Any sentence. You can
use free time activities.
Like: play computer games,
watch films or anything else.
Або будь-що інше. Okay? So, like
an example: I always watch films.
The dice will help you. So, these
are the numbers. I will roll the dice.
We will have a number and the
number is the task for you.
So, 1 is never. 2 is
sometimes. 3 is often.
4 is usually, 5 is always and if I
have 6 – this is roll again, try again.
Okay? For example: I roll the dice
- I have 1 – so I need to say:
“I never watch films” or “I
never do sports”. Okay? Ready?
Yeah.
Let’s try. So… And we have
2. So, Jean? For you – 2.
I sometimes watch films.
Bravo, okay. Zhenia, for
you. I roll the dice. 4.
I usually watch films.
Bravo. Can you do something else
except watching films? Anything else?
I usually… Not do ballet.
Okay.
I usually do sports.
Bravo, let’s try again. 5.
So, always. Jean, for you 5.
I always watch films.
What about anything else?
Apart from watching films.
I always do sports.
Good. And for you,
Zhenia. the last time. 3.
I often play computer games.
Bravo, okay. Now let’s make
it more challenging. Ready?
Okay.
We love challenges. So,
we’ll use two dice. Okay.
And one dice is for
the adverbs of frequency
and the second one is
for free-time activities.
Surf the net, do ballet,
play the piano, go fishing,
watch films and do sports.
Okay? So, let’s try again.
I'm gonna roll two dice. Ready?
Sо, we have 5-5. 5-5, okay?
We’ll start with Zhenia. 5-5.
I always watch films.
Okay, if you speak about Jean
– Jean always watches films.
Can you repeat please?
Jean always watches films.
Bravo, Jean, for you. 1-1.
I never surf the net.
Okay.
But it is not true.
It’s not true, okay.
But this is an example.
Just a game. Can you say about
Zhenia? He never surfs the net.
He never surfs the net.
Bravo, let’s try again. We have 1 and 6.
1 for - do sports and for adverbs
of frequency?
I need to roll again. Okay. 1.
I never do sports.
Bravo. Jean, for you the last one. 2-2.
I sometimes do ballet.
Do ballet, sometimes…
But it’s a secret.
It’s a secret. This is
fortune, probably, you need
to start with ballet? This is nice.
It’s also a really good sport. Agree?
For girls – yes but
for men I think it’s not…
Ah! For men, ballet – normal, normal.
Yes, it’s okay. And I heard
that it’s very difficult to do.
Я переплутав з художньою гімнастикою.
Ah, yeah, okay. So, ballet
is for men as well. Okay.
Yeah, I know Oleksandr Stoyanov.
Bravo! This is good,
this is really good.
It’s a Ukrainian balletmaster.
Yes, yes, this is amazing.
Now it’s a quiz-time.
So, question for you. Ready?
I'm gonna test you now.
Test, a little test. So, the question
is – correct or not? Yes or no?
So, let’s take a look at these
two pictures. Is this do sports?
Yeah, correct.
Okay. Correct.
What about this one? Correct?
Yeah, correct.
Are you sure?
Sure.
It’s not. What’s the
mistake? Do singing?
Ah, go singing!
Go singing, bravo. Go
singing – this is correct.
What about this one?
Correct.
What films, correct.
And what about this one?
Not correct.
What’s the problem?
Do piano.
Do piano? Or what
else? What’s the problem?
Do the piano?
The!
Yes, bravo! We need an article. Play
the piano. Can you repeat, please?
Play the piano.
Bravo, okay. And one more task
for you. I have the pictures.
Name the pictures. So, we
have 4 pictures. What’s this?
Play computer games.
Bravo.
Go fishing.
Okay and, Jean, for you.
Do ballet. Surf the net.
Amazing, excellent! And this is
your homework for the next lesson.
Write 10 sentences about you
using free time activities
and adverbs of frequency.
Like an example:
I always watch films, I never
do ballet, I usually do sports
or I sometimes go
fishing. Like this. Okay?
Okay.
Bravo! Oh, there is a bell. So, we
need to finish our lesson. Thank you!
Thank you!
Thank you.
Побував я сьогодні на уроці
англійської мови, яку я, скажу чесно,
не любив у свої шкільні роки
і вважаю величезною прогалиною
незнання англійської мови.
І я сьогодні побував на уроці
і я кайфонув, мені було легко,
мені було цікаво, наприклад.
Тому такий проект стовідсотково
потрібен, тим паче в такий час.
Достатньо доступно, мені сподобалося.
Я вас прошу – вчіть англійську мову.
Це відкриває настільки
широко перед вами двері,
як би банально не звучала ця фраза.
Тобто ви можете спілкуватися з
людиною з абсолютно іншого куточку
і знаходити щось спільне, і розуміти,
що всі ми маємо щось однакове,
що нас поєднує, і знаходити собі друзів,
і близьких за духом
людей можна будь-де.
Do. Do sports.
Можна казати “offen”, а можна often.
Можна і так і так говорити, насправді.
Всім привіт! Мене звати
Анна Домніч, і саме зараз час
трохи розім’ятись після навчання.
Я думаю, кожен з вас знає, що
спорт – це сила, краса та здоров’я.
І це дуже корисно для нашого організму.
Тож, пропоную вам доєднатись
до наших драйвових руханок
і зарядитись позитивом. Розпочинаємо!
Всім привіт! Ви готові
до нашого уроку спорту?
Я вже дуже засумувала
за нашими руханками.
І у нас сьогодні в гостях
неймовірно талановиті –
Женя Кот
і Наталія Татарінцева.
Тож ви готові, друзі,
до нашого уроку спорту?
Так.
Супер!
Друзі, мені здається
чи продзвенів дзвінок?
Так швиденько закінчився
наш крутий урок.
Я вам дуже вдячна. Ви
неймовірні! Дякую вам!
Дякую!
Круті!
Давайте швидше, бо мені на математику.
До зустрічі!